à l'époque on avait des gagnants j'avais
peur que tu me lâches pour la
concurrence tu as gagné cinq fois le
prix du vol américain
mais c'était il ya longtemps
c'était avant l'accident
avant l'alcool
tu sais combien de gens m'ont dit virer
[Musique]
rien à dire au revoir j'étais toujours
considéré comme un pet eu un lâcher une
carpette mais bon c'est pas une raison
d'être grossier
tu me dois beaucoup mike mais tu m'as
donné ta parole pour revient pas sur sa
parole
en fils raphaël il a des ennuis je veux
le faire sortir du mexique tu veux que
j'aille kidnappé ton mot s'il te plaît
ramel vous êtes seul dit ah koon
allez raffault tu peux sortir maintenant
un ami de la famille touche moi j'étais
démoli grand-père nom de dieu
[Musique]
allez monte on ira quand j'étais le
dirait hockey écoute le seul endroit où
tu vas aller c'est à l'hôpital qui
t'énerve trop c'est pas bon pour toi
aventure
enfants
macho
j'étais beaucoup de choses
que je ne suis plus
[Musique]
bien ce que je pense
être un match chaud semaine pas bien
loin
les gens jouent les machos les gros durs
pour montrer qu'ils ont du cran
[Musique]
tout ce qui leur reste finalement
c'est comme ça pour tout dans la vie on
croit qu'on a toutes les réponses
je m'appelle le match
[Musique]
et puis en vieillissant on se rend
compte qu'on en avait aucune
[Musique]
on doit tous faire des choix dans la vie
petit
toi tu à pékin
[Musique]
il s'appelle match il est comme moi
c'est un coq très fort cédule des
dacquois qu'est-ce qui a rien tu as
envie d' d'appeler ton coque macho ça me
dérange pas